we're joined from our Washington bureau
by URI Friedman he's a staff writer for
The Atlantic clever in global affairs
and US foreign policy or a good morning
good morning how much of a departure is
this from the Obama administration
policy so as a substantive matter it's
only a half way departure Trump
described it as a cancellation of
Obama's policy but that's overstating
the case a little bit we're still going
to maintain diplomatic relations we're
still going to have embassies Cuban
Americans and Americans are still going
to be able to travel the biggest changes
that are twofold first we will no longer
be able to do transactions with guy ASA
affiliated companies gaya is a military
conglomerate it has its arms in many
sectors of the economy and the Trump
administration wants to cut that off so
that the military isn't enriched
secondly the Obama administration
allowed a lot of people to people
exchanges so this could mean that you
could travel to Cuba on your own as long
as you said that's what you're going to
meet Cuban people it was going to be
broadly educational you can make your
own trip to Cuba that's going to be
rolled back now and there's going to be
more of forcing Americans to have to go
with torrid trips so that that those are
the two big changes now with that
there's also a larger kind of strategic
shift the Obama administration looked at
the past decades of u.s. Cuba policy and
said it hasn't worked the Castro regime
is still in place and they tried to move
to more of a policy of let's have more
dialogue with the Cubans and maybe
that'll change things the Trump
administration is really strategically
going back to a decades-old US policy of
saying no we're going to isolate a
problematic regime here and that's the
best way to force change and political
and economic change in Cuba so that is a
real broader shift that is bigger than
the substantive changes yeah or either
this doesn't seem to have been greeted
with open arms in Cuba the president
here in the United States would like to
see a series of democratic reforms in
Cuba how much leverage does he have at
this point with the Castro government he
has some leverage because the Castro
government has been interested in
economic reforms they know the economy
isn't working for Cubans there's a high
rate of unemployment and so I think they
cans for certain economic changes more
private sector reforms and those kinds
of things where I think there is a lot
less
Ridge is politically so Trump said we
want free and fair elections we're not
going to change the Cuban embargo in our
policies until they have kind of almost
full democracy and full capitalism there
I think that's a much harder ask us
administration's been asking that for
decades and it hasn't worked and there's
one reason why which a Cuban dissident
once told me which is that the Castro
regime is not interested in committing
suicide they know that if they allow
free and fair elections they're going to
lose more than half the population wants
a change in the political system in Cuba
and so that's where I think the term
administration's probably going to fall
short just like past administrations
have as well you can get whiplash from
all the changes already Friedman with
the Atlantic in our Washington bureau
thanks Ari